welcome back single women and their cats
mostly vote for Democrats yes the 2022
election showed the rise of a new
Progressive voting Bloc the single woke
female defined as unmarried women
without children with woke meaning both
very liberal and woke up alone next to
some cat puke
so apparently this means Democrats are
competing for the same customers as
sweatpants
oh sexist would say
[Laughter]
in the midterm 68 of them voted for
Democrats the remaining 32 percent wrote
I love coconut water do you have any
coconut water
that was better
[Music]
to be and not because they put on
lockdown weight Mike oh the number of
never married women reaching 30 percent
last year that's a lot it's bad news for
bridal shops and the birth rate but it's
good news for cat rescues and cheap
Chardonnay single serving Lean Cuisines
Haagen-Dazs and of course lifetime
television
and it won't be changing anytime soon
although uh 61 of single men said they
were currently looking for dates only 38
of single women said the same thing
although that may have been a ruse to
avoid requests from Jamie lissow
but it does make sense that single women
would stay single today they can do
anything a man can do including having a
penis
uh oh I don't like that all right
cat uh you are the female here I don't
consider you woke at all isn't it weird
it's like these are the worst women for
women because a they deny sex
differences
and B they don't give any Agency for
women so like women can't even consent
to sex it's like they can change their
mind because they're they're always
victimized or marginalized and like they
can't be strong and they actually can't
be women there are some that are like
that I don't think this describes
everyone I've also only been a married
woman for like a year and a half and I'm
34. yeah so I was one of these people I
was like a unmarried childless woman for
a long time and you know I it could
happen to anybody
I'm I'm proof of that these people like
I'm not looking I'm like neither was I
it'll just it'll get you yes um it's
like a covered it'll get you you have no
idea but I you know I think that
not everybody who is a conservative is
socially conservative and judgmental of
non-traditional Lifestyles but a lot of
people who are judgmental of
non-traditional lifestyles are
conservative and I think that maybe some
people can't see past those things and
you should focus on being a bit of a
bigger tent and less on social issues
Democrats do it too obviously they keep
their own party too I don't know what
she said Jamie I just worry about you
because you uh this could hurt you
because you need to find a woman to talk
to uh in your garage yeah I don't
believe this no because I've been
looking
and so the I guess they're also Liars
um I seriously I don't even feel
qualified to I've tried you know you
know me I'm going to be single forever I
try there's nowhere to go and I want you
get farmersonly.com is there's only
farmers yes I couldn't do that I can't
go on mash.com I'm not an arsonist
um I can't go on I just go screw it I'm
just gonna get a sandwich so I went on
grindr.com
I'm just glad I ordered the six inch it
actually says
ah it says right here
that was just don't say that one right
here it's tough though I I feel bad for
these women I feel bad for myself dating
after 40 is like moving without hiring
professional movers you know there's
dust everywhere things don't fit all the
boxes are dented
what oh my God
I don't know what that means they
ordered the big subscribe
Tyrus most of your fans are women who
have been married for 50 years listen I
did my part I gave four of them kids I'm
trying yeah
there's only so much you can do and
there's only so many hours a day you can
hide from your phone you took the heat
off me I tried you know I I did my part
but at some point you got to throw your
hands up the problem for them is like
here's here's the deal fellas we're ugh
when we're in our 20s we're like rabbits
you know when we're 30s we become like
lions when we get in those 40s we're
like yeah I made it this far we're
focused on other things like building a
new car or buying my first house with a
garage or whatever it is we no longer
want to deal with the courtship so the
guys start focusing on other things so
then there's that group
that were just you know and how do I say
this um I'm scared yeah
too [ __ ] to go out with so you just
leave them to themselves and then these
poor cats get stuck with them because
the the cats I highly recommend getting
a cat as a single woman I don't know if
I'd be alive
good all the pressure they put on the
cat who's thinking of the cat voice
they have the comp like here's the
difference a cat as long as you're
feeding them they'll stay but when you
start finishing our sentences we want to
leave and they you know what I'm saying
when we have little nicknames and they
want to dress this up and do all that
kind of stuff we want to get the hell
out of town the cat is like as long as
I'm being fed they'll hang around but as
soon as you stop feeding them or you
leave the window open they're out yeah
that's like Mike Baker you leave the
window open he's gone I'm done yeah so
it's like that agents that's how I leave
the Fox Building yeah an open window
open the window uh care to add anything
uh uplifting about this you're a happily
married man you're on your sixth
marriage yeah yeah me and uh and uh Tony
Randall uh and uh Larry King
um no I I got all when it comes to
talking about the single woke uh women
um I I couldn't imagine being in the
dating pool like Jamie me I couldn't
imagine that and I'm working for you
find a hobby yeah find a hobby a hobby
yeah yes at least travel to the world
you could you could you could get your
friends to help you raise a garage
wouldn't that be nice you should get a
cat yeah
a lot of this is funny but also feels
bad inside
[Laughter]
I'm gonna move on but that was fun hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else